it's crazy that the word is available
for sale
and and i'm kind of all over the place
here um
and i'm not defending anybody for saying
it i mean it's
you know you hear it i hear it all the
time i hear it all the time you hear it
from people
in these days when i when i was young
you would hear it
well i guess i would hear when i was
young growing up from people that were
racist and i would hear it from
music you know nwa and
and so it's weird because it's like a
word that's used in hip-hop culture
you know with the a at the end and um
and so it's just it's it's interesting
and i don't want to be afraid to like
think about things you know
but one thing that really made me upset
about
uh about the n-word is the
way that media outlets cover it
and the way that media outlets cover it
so somebody says it right
they take it and they make articles
that say at the top of the and these are
outlets that would never even
probably cover the person that if
there's a famous person that says it
you know uh you can be a white dude in a
starter jacket and say it all day
you could be six nine and say it all day
you know
but if you're popular and you say it the
media they cramp down on you
and what gets me um
is that they use it the media puts
inward
in the title of articles
so they get you to go click on it
and then then you're reading the article
you're watching it or whatever it is
so they are making money off of it
and man that burns me up to think that
because then you and i bet if you follow
the companies
who is who's who are earning
money from the clicks and the people
watching or reading
i bet it leads right to white pockets i
guarantee you that
so man it's just crazy that people that
would never even cover this artist
at all or this celebrity at all suddenly
they're writing articles that are
clickable
that they're making money on so they're
basically
making money off of the n word
they're making money off of it
and man that really i mean that just
yeah man that just makes it makes me mad
bro that make me just
mad dude make me feel like a damn just
like six badgers are climbing up and
down my spine you wanna know what a
badger sounds like i'll tell you
[Music]
and let's get to the angry one
that's what it makes me feel like
you know because you have companies that
don't care and now that so they're
basically you
they are using the n-word to make money
and that's that man that burns me up
it just burns me up and i think it
should burn anybody up
you know yeah and it's kind of wild in
the media like somebody can apologize
for
for for for uh saying something they
shouldn't
somebody can apologize for using a
racial slur but the immediate they don't
want a
apology somebody could say well i'll
i'll do better
but that's not enough for them
they want to just roast it they want to
take over they want to
they want you to burn
and that's just wild to me like
don't no matter what someone does don't
we want them to have a
don't we want them to feel
you know you want someone to feel
reprimanded
but don't you want some don't like what
if it was your kid that did it like it's
just crazy people would
ostracize so much and just denounce
like there's you are worthless
and uh like what do they want you to
kill yourself what do they want
do they want you to lose your own life
by your own hand
by a dagger by a sword
you know i just don't understand
sometimes
because somebody's saying they'll do
better i mean it's but i guess you know
you need to believe them
but man and then what if
and and what don't any of these writers
who write these articles what if your
kid does something wrong one day
what if your husband your brother your
what if someone you
do you want them to be burned like that
i just don't i i don't know
and then it's wild that they'll see you
know it's like they shouldn't
we should they should just get rid of
the word
they should get rid of the word because
you can buy it online i mean website is
mapple music some of you whatever
platform they're making money
you could go listen to it you could buy
it
maybe white people shouldn't be allowed
to buy stuff with the word in it
because if you sell somebody enough
produce
you know when sometimes a strawberry
rolls out their mouth
you can't be shocked but you're the one
vending it to them
and i'm not saying that's the case in
this instance exactly i'm not saying
that but i'm saying that that's a real
thing
you know and i think there's a lot of
people out there of color who feel the
same way who are just tired of
the music that's like you know kill
these n words and all this [ __ ] it's
just
it's i don't know and look
i'm just a white person so i only have
my experience
you know i grew up around a lot of black
people i used to be in a group called uh
nfl and i can't say the whole name of
the group but i can say for life
um
dude i used to ride my bike in in the
school in the morning
and johnny smith and the boys they would
come and jump on my bike
and they would call me to a bus when i'd
come in they would call me the n-word
bus hey here comes the n-word bus and
they would all pile on my bike
and i'd be sitting there just rolling
just a damn i mean
literally the basketball team deep
and now we just you know man dude my
quads was
beefy son my quads
was beefy you know what i'm saying
damn chickafalla you know it
and they would call me the n word bus
here come the n word bus
and my parents didn't say it you know
my dad said it one time a black guy
stabbed him with a screwdriver and he
said it
so i'll be honest but um
i don't know man some of you know it's
it's just
like there's just a lot of red tape out
there but then look
that's only my perspective and i'm not
saying that it's right but i don't want
to feel like i can't
think and talk about it um
because i also know that it's a hurtful
word
you know uh but i also know that
the media just there's no court of law
there's just
there's no examination of that kind of
thing of
of what was going on you know
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one
you